So let's jump into the engine and see what it takes to get a character set up with a
full body AK system within Control Rig.
What we're going to need is to make sure that we have the full body AK plugin activated.
We'll need a skeletal mesh for our character, a control rig asset and a handful of controls.
The first thing we need to do is check that we have the plugin activated.
So if we come up to edit in the top left here, down to the plugins window and search
for full body, that should get us there.
So we can see that we have the plugin activated already, but if you don't in your project,
just tick this box here and then I think you get a restart option down at the bottom, that
will just restart your project and then have the plugin loaded.
Now that we know the plugin is running, let's create a new control rig for our character.
So if you find your character skeletal mesh, right click, come up to create at the top here
and then down to control rig.
And that'll create you a new control rig and if we double click that to open, you'll
see it's already referencing in your character that you created it from.
I'm just going to rename this to be our FBIK control rig.
And if I double click to open, I'll just dock it in the top here.
The first thing we need to do is create some controls.
Now these will be our effectors for the FBIK solver and the goals for our IK chains to
reach towards essentially.
So we'll want one for the head, one for each hand and one for the ball of each foot.
So I'm going to select all of these bones and create controls from them.
So our head, our hand left, our hand right and further down here we'll have our ball
R and our ball L.
I'll right click these, come to new and add controls for selected.
And if we scroll to the bottom, we've got all of our new controls here that are at the
locations of the bones that we had selected.
Now I'm just going to customize the look of these a bit so we can see at a glance which
control is which.
So for the hands, I'll just change them to box thick.
And for the left side, if I select both of the left hand controls here, I'm just going
to turn them to a blue color.
And with the head control, it's actually inside the head at the moment.
So I'm just going to change it to a circle and I'm going to adjust the rotation of the
shape transform and scale it up probably to let's say three.
And I'll change the color of that as well.
So they're all quite distinct now.
I think something I might do is just adjust the scale of this in the Z axis alone.
Let's go something like eight, just so it's a little easier to select and you can see
it a bit better in the viewport.
Now as I said, these controls are going to be our effectors for the FBI case over.
And this means we're going to need to get their locations to feed that into the FBI
case node.
So if I highlight all of our controls here and I left click and drag them all into our
control regraph and choose get control.
This is going to get the transforms of all of these controls.
If I just space them out a little bit so that we can read them a bit better.
You can see that we have an individual get transform node for all of those controls.
And now we need to set up the logic to tell the system how these controls will be driving
our bones.
So let's first get the brains of the operation and search for an FBI case node.
So if I right click in the rig graph and search for FBI case, it's the full body IK that
we're looking for.
The first thing we need to do is actually set the root of the solver.
And for this, we're going to use the pelvis or the hips of our character.
And the reason we do this is to ensure that the solver actually starts from the true base
of where the motion occurs rather than the root of our skeletal mesh.
You can set this to be any bone on your skeletal mesh depending on your setup, but to get the
best results from something like a biped or quadruped that's reaching towards something
or adjusting its pose to keep aligned with the ground plane, you'll want to set this
more often than not as the pelvis or hips of your character.
So we'll just set that there.
Now we're going to set up the effectors.
And this is where we tell the node which bones we want to use essentially as the end of our
IK chains and which controls will be the goals for those bones.
What we're going to do under the effectors heading here, we'll add an array element with
the little plus.
This will give us just a host of options under our first item in the array.
And the first item we're going to set up for the bone is going to be our head.
And we'll just work down the effectors that we have here or the controls that we have
here.
So if we search for our head bone here and then connect the transform of our head control
to the transform of our first effector here, that means that the head control is going
to drive the head bone.
So if we were to connect this up straight away and just hit compile, when we grab our
head control here, you can see that we're moving the entire character.
And that's just because we haven't pinned anything in place here or we don't have any
other effectors set up.
But you can see that already we've got some movement there and we've got something working.
So let's just do that for the rest of our controls here.
So if we add in your effector, this will be the hand L and we connect those transforms
up, add another one, hand R, connect those transforms up, add one more, all R and the
last one.
Oh, if I hit that properly, there we go.
This will be ball L.
Now, if I compile that, you'll see that when we grab any of these effectors now, all of
the other IK chains or the, all of the other effectors essentially are pinning themselves
in place.
So you can actually pull these around and manipulate your character.
And you can see that really it's kind of that quick to get something, something that's
able to adjust the pose of your character's whole body with just a few controls and the
FBIK node.
Now we have a couple of settings we can look at for each of the effectors first.
And that is the position, I just zoom in here, position, rotation and strength alphas.
And the position and rotation alphas work in the same way.
One is just for translation and one is for rotation.
And they both blend between the bones current position or rotation and the effectors current
position or rotation.
So if we were to set this on the left hand to zero, for example, you'll see that as we
move it around, it's no longer affecting the position of our hand bone.
But as we rotate it, it will affect the rotation because that's still set to one.
So you can kind of customize these and update them and change them to fit your character.
And the strength alpha determines how much the bone will pull towards the effector or
the control.
So if this is set to zero, the bone is not going to pull towards the effector.
But the rest of the chain from the root to the effector is going to slightly resist the
motion of other effectors, meaning that it can act a bit like a stabilizer of sorts for
part of the body that you don't want to behave in a purely FK fashion.
So if I was to set this on the hand to zero and then try and pull it around, you'll see
that it doesn't drive the hand directly, but it still has an effect on the root and the
whole chain going from the root to the end bone, which in this case is our left hand.
So if I was to grab a different effector, you can see that we get a little bit of resistance.
And if someone was leaning to the left, their arm would kind of go out a little bit to kind
of stabilize.
And it's helpful for things like that, essentially.
I just send that back to default.
So with our current settings, if I just make the window a bit bigger here, because we won't
be needing the rig hierarchy, with our current settings, you can see that everything is reacting
to the effectors being pulled around.
But things I think could look a little better.
Like we've got the hips moving quite a lot here, so they're rotating quite a bit.
And the legs, both of them, they're very, very stiff.
So we expect them to sort of be bending at the knee here.
And I think the ankle is probably rotating too far when we lift the leg and drop it down.
You can see both of them are rotating quite a bit there.
So we're going to try and fix these by adjusting the bone settings for the affected bones in
the chains.
So that's going to be things like the pelvis, our leg bones, and our feet bones.
And we do that by adding the affected bones to our bone settings array.
So I'm just going to minimize the effectors here just to clear up sort of the visuals
of the node.
And under the bone settings, I'm going to add a new element to the array.
And all the settings that come up here are going to allow you to essentially control
the stiffness and limit the rotation of the bones that you specify.
So first of all, we're going to try and fix the rotation of the hips that they're going
a bit too far.
So the bone we want to update or we want to add some settings to will be the pelvis.
And we're going to increase the rotation stiffness essentially.
So if we put that to something like 0.8, now when we lift the foot, you'll see that we
get a lot less rotation in the hips there.
And it makes things look just a bit more natural for our character.
And if we were to increase the position stiffness, say 0.5 for example, you'll see that that
doesn't move quite as much.
I can put this also up to one.
And it's just essentially a lot harder for the hips to move up and down.
The controls or the effectors that you're moving need to work a lot harder to pull the
hips around.
But we're going to leave that at zero for now because I think that's what works best
for our character here.
Something you can also do is set preferred angles.
Now this is essentially controlling which way the bone bends when the limb is compressed
by the effector.
And it's great for things like your knees or your elbows.
And we're going to use this to resolve the stiffness in the legs by adjusting the settings
for both the thigh and the calf.
Coming back to our bone settings, we'll add another array element.
Let me just minimize this so we can see a little better when we add it.
And let's first search for the thigh.
So let's work on the left hand side first.
Now under the preferred angles, this is where we can specify which rotation axis we would
prefer to rotate around.
So we prefer the knee to bend around.
And for that, it would be best to check the local rotation axis of our knee joint or our
thigh joint.
And to do that, if we come up to our options, our view options in the top left and turn
on display axis on selection.
And then if we search for our thigh L, we can see that if I zoom in here, we'll be bending
or rotating around the Z axis.
So that'll be going forwards and backwards with our leg.
So inside the preferred angles here, if we set our Z axis to minus 45, just because this
is something we checked previously, and give our leg a bend, we can see that they almost
worked.
However, we need to check on something called use preferred angles.
So without that, it won't be taking any of these values into account.
So if I check that on, you can see immediately we're looking a whole lot better already.
So comparing that to the right hand side, where we don't have any preferred angle set
up.
You can see that as we pull that up and down, it's remaining quite stiff, but the left side
is reacting a lot more how you would expect.
Now let's do the same thing for the calf.
So I'm going to add another bone setting, find our calf L.
And under the preferred angles, let's check the preferred angle of our calf again, or
the local rotation axis.
So it looks to be along the Z axis again.
But this time we wanted to rotate backwards, so rotate the other way.
So inside Z, I'm going to put a value of 90.
And again, check on use preferred angles so that it actually takes those values into account.
And now when we raise the foot up, you can see that we've got a great bend in the knee.
And it's just acting a lot more natural and looking a lot better for our character here
with the pose that they're in.
And these are some things that you can play with and update for your character to get
it looking how you want.
And it's great these preferred angles to set things like any sort of bone you want to rotate
in a specific direction.
It doesn't have to be like arms and legs.
It can be anything that your character needs.
You can update those angles here and just have a bit more control over how the character
is going to react when these effectors are being pulled around.
So let's just do the same for the right side so that we have a symmetrical character essentially
that's working properly.
So we add in your bone array, search for our IR.
Click on Use Preferred Angles and just test that out.
And you can see that whatever value you put in here, it does adhere to.
So set that to negative.
And add one for the right hand calf.
So calf R.
These preferred angles, 90 degrees.
There we go, things are looking a lot nicer now.
And both of our legs are acting much more naturally and much more how you would expect
if one was being pulled around.
And you can see as I go side to side, it's always bending in that Z axis so it's not
accidentally sort of breaking the knee at all.
Now the last thing we're going to take a look at within the bone settings are the limits.
And that's these three options here one per axis.
Now this isn't super necessary here because we're already getting quite good results.
But just for the demo, we'll take a look at how the limit settings work essentially.
Now limits, they allow us to clamp or limit the range of motion of a bone on an individual
axis.
And there are three different settings for it.
So we've got free.
Now that allows the bone to just move freely.
There is limited.
Now this allows the movement only within a specific range of the min and max values that
we set here.
And this is up to or minus 180 degrees.
And the values are relative to your reference pose rather than the pose that your character
is currently in.
And the third option we have is locked.
Now this completely disables the movement along the axis that you lock.
So what we're going to do is tweak the ankle slightly here and limit its range of motion
so that if we were to push this foot up really high, the foot wouldn't penetrate through
the shin there, through the lower leg.
So we'll go through the same process, add a new bone setting.
This is going to be our foot bone.
So foot L will do here.
And we'll just double check the rotation axis that we want to edit.
And it is along the Z axis again.
So here we've already tested these settings and I'm going to set the Z axis to limited
and set the minimum to minus 60 and the maximum to 60.
So if I push this foot right the way up now, you'll see that when we reach a certain point,
which is just around here, the ankle no longer keeps rotating so it doesn't penetrate through
the lower leg.
I'll just revert these back to zero.
You can see the difference there.
As we keep raising it up, that ankle just keeps bending.
So if you have any instances with your character where you need to fix that or limit the bone,
that's how you would do it.
And I'll just duplicate that for the right hand side.
So find our foot R, come down to the Z axis, limit that at minus 60 and 60.
So now both feet are working in the same way.
So with tweaking those various bone settings, we actually fixed our character and got them
looking more natural.
So with less hip bend there and the knees are bending in the correct direction and the
ankles aren't bending too far, so we have something a little more realistic for our
character.
Now depending on the needs of your rig, there may be cases where you want to exclude bones
from the FBIK solve.
And this can be useful when correcting unnatural looking poses or if you just want to simplify
the FBIK behavior.
So excluding bones is highly recommended versus using bone settings and adding lots
of bones that are sort of fully stiff or locked because this reduces the calculations that
the solver has to do and essentially reduces the impact on performance because there are
fewer things that the solver has to calculate for if you're excluding them.
So if we take a look at an example here, what we can do is move the head into an awkward
sort of position.
And you can see that if the head's being pulled around, the body's not really reacting how
you would expect.
So I'm going to exclude the neck and the spine here to try and get a bit more of a comfortable
pose.
So I'm going to add six bones here and I'm just going to start at the top of the chain
and work my way down.
So neck two, neck one, you can see they've already gained something a bit more natural,
arguably that is still a little strange, but the whole body has come down to meet the head
now.
If I exclude some more of these spine bones, we should get something as little more as
you expect.
So as this head is being pulled around, the spine is still bending at the first spine
joint because they're not excluded that as well as the pelvis.
And it's keeping it a little straighter to try and meet the head effector.
So if you have certain scenarios where that's something you need to do and stop sort of
a strange pose that you have on your character or improve the pose of your character to reach
the effector or the IK goal, then excluding bones is a great way to do that.
And again, this removes bones from the solvers calculations.
So it makes things a little bit more performant versus adding lots of bones to the bone settings
and then setting them as locked or the stiffness to 100%.
The last thing to take a look at with the FBIK node here are just some of the settings
that are available to tweak things on a more global scale.
So if I close that and open settings here, we have the iterations here.
Basically, the number of times that the solver will loop through and calculate all the positions
of the bones.
This helps with convergence, which is essentially trying to make the bones reach the effectors.
Increasing this value will increase the CPU cost of the node, but it can be necessary
when you have a lot of bones in your character.
Next we have the mass multiplier.
And this acts as a sort of global stiffness, similar to the position and rotation stiffness
that we saw under the bone settings, but it applies to all of the bones at once.
And typically you'd work within a range of 0 to 10 for this.
So if the IK solve seems to be acting quite erratically, increasing the minimum mass multiplier
might just fix that.
So for example, this can sometimes happen with very large scale characters.
So internally, the body is segmented by the node and held together with constraints.
So this is from the effectors to the bones.
That's just sort of the behind the scenes working of the IK node.
And the mass multiplier is proportional to the length of the body.
So that means that longer bones will rotate less than smaller bones.
And that means that they'll rotate less per iteration, which means you might just need
to play with these values together to get the sort of results that you want.
You might need to increase the iterations a little bit, as well as increasing the mass
multiplier a little bit.
But that tends to apply to, again, just very large characters with either long bones or
a lot of bones in their skeleton.
Allow stretch does what you think.
So it will allow your bones to stretch towards the effector.
So with that turned on and off, you can see that actually the length of the bones increases,
stretching towards the effector to reach the end goal.
Updating the root behavior will determine how the root acts.
So you can see here that pre-pull is default, and by default, it will translate and rotate
the root and all the children when you're pulling the effectors around.
If you pin to input, this locks the root to the current pose that the root is in.
So the current animation pose that is playing.
If you set it to free, it treats the root bone like any other and allows it to freely
move according to whatever bone settings you have applied to it.
And these bone settings, if we drop down the box here, will allow you to update the rotation
and position along each individual axis to sort of tweak to your heart's content.
The global pull chain alpha can be used to rotate the entire limb controlled by an effector
to point at it before the solver runs.
So if you use this in conjunction with preferred angles, it can really help to pull the skeleton
into a desired shape before the constraints are solved.
Now it's on by default, set to one, though it's sometimes desirable to turn it off because
it can make limbs a little overreactive or even reduce it.
And by that, if I just drag this down here, for example, to show you, if I slowly increase
this number, you'll see that the sort of rotation on all the limbs gets multiplied.
And you can end up with some funky results, and that's what we mean by overreactive,
like they're bending a bit too much.
The maximum angle will just determine how much a bone can rotate per iteration.
And over relaxation here will essentially push the constraints beyond their normal amount
in an attempt to speed up convergence.
Now this can help with some of your posing, but it can come at the cost of stability.
So the range to work within here is just between one and two.
So as you can see, there are a lot of different settings that we just went over and a lot
of different options available to tweak and sort of change the posing of your character.
Now I would say try not to get too bogged down with them.
My advice would be focus mainly on your bone settings and your excluded bones, as they're
going to be the thing that help you out the most when fixing your posing in most common scenarios.